tis the season for favorite Oprah's
Favorite Things yeah alright a burial
for us we've been doing this for 23
years and this is as you know an Oprah
staple making a list and checking it 70
nine
Oprah's calling her favorites with help
from a couple of powerhouse celebs happy
to see you
[Music]
we've got some makeup from Lady gaga
you know little-known fact Oprah has
always liked makeup
really
gaga's makeup kid prices in at 96 bucks
while Sarah Jessica Parker offers
backpack she designed at $245 you know
more and more people are carrying
backpacks you wear this yes because
they're so efficient yeah exactly you
know Sarah Jessica came in surprised to
her that was good so that made the cut
the favorite things issue of Oh magazine
drops November 19th the list most
expensive item this stationary bike will
set you back to grams there are actually
several truffle items on the list
because Oprah loves all things truffles
when Oprah goes to a restaurant some
people think it's tacky she doesn't but
she'll pull out the truck sauce hmm
comes in black and white truffles so she
loves that what is it like behind the
scenes when Gail and Oprah pop open a
few too many bottles alone very good
question Rachel because Gail doesn't
drink and I think it's irritating to her
because she said Stedman doesn't drink
either so it's not always a fungus in
there that's just the three of us